good morning believe nation today's
message is start with curiosity over you
leo babauta
I wake up every mood miss French Peavey
go so I actually I had someone Twitter I
asked people like what's the think the
one change that has helped you the most
and one person I really love this
blessed because it matches up with mine
which is that he replaced opinions with
curiosity hmm and I love that because to
me a lot of people get to this point
where they think they know something and
when you think you know something that's
when learning like I've done you're done
there but if you just think okay I might
know something but let's find out more
maybe it's wrong yeah maybe there's more
to learn maybe there's a next step and
there always is more to learn and so
that's to me if you just start with
curiosity rather than like I think I
know it or I don't need to know it or
there's no way I'm going to know how to
that you know that's that's a much
better place to start and it's a lot
like learning new things and trying new
things I love this message because i
found that often the most successful
people are the ones who are the most
curious the ones who love what they do
the ones who are passionate about the
subject matter that their reign and you
look at the top people in any industry
they love what they're doing and they're
intensely curious about how things work
and how to make things better I think a
lot of entrepreneurs make the mistake of
going into a business just trying to
make money and they're not actually
curious about their industry they're not
passionate about it they just see it as
a hard opportunity to make a quick buck
and those are the entrepreneurs who
don't make it those the entrepreneurs
that fail and a good question ask
yourself is and my curious about this
business or not am I putting that hours
of research into figure out how to make
things better is it fun and enjoyable
for me and if it's not then you really
should move on and do something else so
remember if you want to be successful
you have to be genuinely curious about
the industry that you're in so the
question of the day today is what are
you curious about I'm curious to find
out leave in the comments below and I'm
going to join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and i'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso I work
expresso give me go